[Musique]
washington résonnent au son des cloches
500 coût symbolique pour marquer ce
tragique cap des 500 milles morts de
lakovic 19
[Musique]
derrière les statistiques des visages
des histoires de famille éplorée
[Musique]
samantha dias 30 ans infirmière et mère
monoparentale laisse trois enfants aux
soins de leur grand mère
[Musique]
je n'attends coup elle au jeune père de
famille de 32 ans qui ne verra pas non
plus ses enfants grandir
le docteur susan boyle est aussi décédé
de lakovic 19
elle se plaignait du racisme qu'elle
subissait lors de son traitement
chaque histoire est tragique
le pays vont honorer ses victimes à the
nation on ne peut pas laisser les choses
aller dit joe biden à ce moment que nous
avons perdu plus d'américains ont
maintenant dit il que durant les deux
guerres mondiales et la guerre du
vietnam ou tout au moins comme band joe
biden qui a connu plusieurs deuils sur
huit son fils beau sa première femme et
sa fille a voulu réconforter la nation
américaine au pétrole
ils ne seront jamais vraiment parti
dit-il cas elles seront toujours dans
vos coeurs
un moment de recueillement pour le pays
le drapeau américain est en berne et le
sera pendant cinq jours sur tous les
établissements fédéraux
[Musique]
puis une minute de silence à la chambre
des représentants à midi avant le début
des séances
même si le nombre de cas de coronavirus
est élevée la tendance est à la baisse
- de nouveaux cas par jour moins
d'hospitalisations selon les autorités
médicales les cas de kevin 19 diminue
dit-elle en moyenne de 74 % par rapport
à la mi-janvier les campagnes de
vaccination se poursuivre soit 1,7
million de doses administrées chaque
jour partout au pays
la nouvelle administration est
déterminée à enrayer le virus
je vois la lumière au bout du tunnel dit
le gouverneur de la californie
nous avons encore des défis il faut
rester vigilant les optimistes à la fois
douces new world le pays va sourire
encore dit joe biden je vous le promets
que ce méchoui monde au jogging et pour
tenir cette promesse joe biden va
relancer l'économie et combattre la
pandémie avec son plan de sauvetage de
1900 milliards de dollars et il espère
que le congrès va adopter son projet de
loi si elle est votée les galeristes
radio-canada washington